good good morning Millennials welcome
back to the morning toast and no my God
sorry we need a Monday song we need a
song for Monday to get us in the morning
toast welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome to the morning
toast happy Monday hope everyone had a
blessed relaxing and recharging weekend
hey Jax how you doing I'm doing good
excited to be back with my girly girl
excited to hear about your weekend
because I think your weekend looked
really fun whereas mine was filled with
Mama Tings and a sick baby so how's
World Genie yeah today's episode is
delayed because the most important thing
on the planet needed our attention he
had to go to the doctor I heard he had a
fever give us tell us everything so he
had a fever all weekend in and out it
was pretty low grade it never hit you
know the the scary numbers scary but
then it turned like that the amount of
days that he was feverish was becoming
the concerning thing concerning so
bright and early this morning I took him
to the doctor to make sure that
everything was okay and if not to treat
whatever was bothering him and he's okay
it's just a little virus it will pass
you just have to keep treating the
symptoms so I'm glad for that but yes it
definitely backed up our schedule and it
took over my whole weekend so I don't
have that much exciting news to report
other than that I read so much and
whenever we do our book talk can't wait
to share
so we have a crazy episode for you guys
today obviously we have so much to catch
up on from the weekend last night was
the house of the Dragon episode that
literally like
like changed my life I dreamed of incest
like it was beyond and Mondays usually
our uh unburdened yourselves day I just
feel like today is going to be really
long and we're already a little delayed
we're gonna switch unburden yourselves
to Tuesday so we can just have more
balanced episodes because I don't want
to be rushed today I want to talk about
everything I also absolutely have to
give the people an update on the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills because it's
low-key gotten so crazy and like we have
not done a recap in two months I'm
totally caught up
um and I'll dive into it in the TV recap
but I just want to say like the energy I
will be bringing is Justice for Kathy so
if you don't agree with that get the
[ __ ] out cool and I'm caught up on
Southern Charm
covering all our bases it's just such an
enjoyable show really even though
there's no drama I just enjoy these
people I'm even enjoying Patricia that's
how great wow yep coming around on Miss
Pat
wow Jackie wow I know
um so I had a fabulous weekend I knew it
was gonna be fabulous because we have
been planning Brian's baby shower for
yesterday Sunday
um for a few months and it finally was
the day and it was honestly like
it was giving Andy's baby shower you
know like it was not like other baby
showers we had drag queens it was lit we
had Spritz we had Housewives we had a
Nobel Peace Prize winner like it was no
I wish Lima Bowie she is kind of like a
really big deal and she's like Brian's
like Mentor
um so she flew all the way from Ghana
and it was she made she first saw she
made him a quilt like for the baby
oh my God it was so like I literally the
whole day was either like dancing or
crying like it was so emotional but it
was also like I was draining like to be
so emotional for so many hours she made
a speech it was first of all just to
hear like a Nobel Peace Prize winner
speak it's like a once in a lifetime
opportunity and she's so close with
Brian and and her whole family is and it
was so it was so sweet and she like made
him matching outfits for him and the
baby like a pair of shorts and a shirt
for both of them did she upstage your
speech
so I did request that Lama speak after
me because I was not um gonna follow a
Nobel Peace Prize winner when I'm like
borderline moronic with a handmade quilt
yeah no like it just wasn't fair so like
I was like funny goofy silly and
everyone enjoyed it and then she went so
it was like the perfect progression it
would have been so sat if I had to go
after her what was the thesis of your
speech
just that like Brian is like a dad to me
like he's always like literally taking
care of everyone and like I think a lot
of people and he said in his speech I
vlogged the whole thing by the way it's
up on the patreon I got my whole speech
in there Brian Soul speech in there all
the celebs who were there I was like
being thirsty
um there was it was star-studded yeah
Brian was basically like you know people
have been saying to me like aren't you
nervous and for a moment he was like you
know is this going to be weird not to
have like a traditional mom for my son
but first of all and the whole party was
women
um I think Ben was literally one of
three straight guys there he was like
I'm just surrounded by so many wonderful
women and I have such a great mom and
like I'm not even worried about it at
all and I feel so prepared because my
friends are like toddlers like Claudia
and John and it was honestly so true
because I said in my speech we both
really said the same thing I was like
Brian's literally our dad and he was
like my friends are literally my
children so I'm ready like I'm not even
nervous I know that this is what I'm
gonna be great at that's beautiful
Claudia that's beautiful thank you I did
you know of course have to sing in my
speech Toni Braxton I sing a Toni
Braxton song that Brian and I love
um we're always saying like Brian you
mean the world to me or just like Jackie
you looking so beautiful like it truly
means the world we're always saying that
and it's you mean the world to me by
Toni Braxton and I I said like Brian
ever since I met him like he's really
taught me so much he's showed me the
world and it means and it means the
world to me in the words of Toni Braxton
and then I sang you mean the world to me
you are my everything it was really
beautiful nice I'm excited to watch the
Vlog I wanted like I like to watch all
your Vlogs on my TV it's a whole
production uh but I had a sick baby so I
get like a 24-hour you get all the time
you need thank you and and Harry loves
watching your Vlogs too so I want to
wait till he can enjoy it so Margaret we
had it at Margaret Joseph's house and I
feel like her house has been a
conversation on the show for a long time
and I just have to say like it was
unbelievable if I ever have like a home
I will be hiring Margaret as my
decorator and Joe is my contractor like
I like there's like a certain style that
like
it's like I really like it but I could
never put it together myself it's like
these kind of crazy patterns and I would
never walk into a store and get it but I
wish that I would because it looked so
Chic her house is gorgeous yeah gorgeous
that's what I'm learning about like
buying furniture and doing design on a
house it's like not I Know It Feels Like
Everything You should be so obsessed
with but and it's really hard to do this
when you're buying furniture but like
sometimes you won't be obsessed with it
till you see it with everything else
sometimes you have to get a couple
things that you like
and but they really work and complement
the things that you are obsessed with
yeah it was so beautiful and her and
Lexi really did the majority of the
planning like there was a host committee
and we met one time and then Margaret
and Lexi literally did everything and it
was so well done there was a mentalist
there who was blowing people's [ __ ]
minds like literally there was a girl
there and he was like think of the name
of your first kiss and so she's thinking
it he's touching her finger and like
saying letters and just like reading her
facial cues and then he writes down on a
Post-It John Sullivan and she's like The
Mentalist is like what was the name of
your first kiss and she said John
Sullivan and literally Jackie the entire
room started screaming like it was crazy
did he do anything to you
yes he had Margot think of the most
random celebrity that she could think of
it's in the Vlog and he touched her
finger said a bunch of letters and
numbers read her mind and it was Queen
Elizabeth
okay well
so in Margot in his defense like Margot
he said choose the most random person
she's literally not random especially
right now no couldn't be more relevant
top of mind yeah okay that's a Margo
error a hundred percent how is our dear
sister
she's good I was really with her the
whole weekend Friday night you know it's
fashion week so like everyone was out
and about and like I've been trying to
like not go out as much because I've
been just [ __ ] hating being hungover
but like it was fabulous like people
were out I wanted to see him be seen in
CNB scene
so on Friday night I went out and
actually the craziest thing happened me
and Margo we were just like drinking
with a bunch of the girlies and Kendall
Jenner and Devin Booker walked in and so
obviously like the whole restaurant was
quaking
um but they were also quaking because
Ben Simmons was at this restaurant so
literally the whole restaurant was like
silent as they were just watching this
interaction between Kendall her man and
her X-Men
um nothing happened and then eventually
got boring like watching celebrities
like just be pretty and famous is
low-key [ __ ] boring yeah we're not
really big on people watching as people
yeah like that's the thing about
celebrities it's like honestly like
they're kind of boring
in person they're just people they're
just people yeah just people
they're just people
um but it was fabulous like you know the
city is is in a it's in good form you
know lots going on it's been really
looking quite fabulous all the facts
everyone's in town There's fabulous
parties like it's good yeah yeah and it
looks like you and Margo were right
there in the mix all week yes and
Saturday night we just went out again
with the girlies I saw you know some of
the out of town influencer girlies
sabotage girlies
um I saw Shannon thank God I needed a
Shannon fix and it was it was even
better than I remembered I'm so happy
for you no and I'm like wasted in the
bathroom I'm like Shannon you need to
start a patreon I would buy it in a
second you really would no I would and
like Shannon's so fabulous and like she
should start like a vlog YouTube but
like she shouldn't give that [ __ ] away
for free I'm like Shannon start a
patreon I think it's a good idea that is
a good idea
and she was like drunk and she was just
like indulging me she was like yeah
totally I should
we're like what's patreon no and she's
like
can we stop talking about work no you
can never but that's just because you're
a mobile like you can never turn it off
I'm sure Google energy I'm sure so
honestly waking up this morning I do not
feel like it was the weekend this was
like a booked and busy weekend I didn't
have any time to read or lay in bed and
that stunk but it was fun being a
fabulous socialite you know every now
and then yeah and it sounds like like I
feel like so often you go out and it's
just not fun and it's not fabulous I
feel like this weekend was that and so
I'm happy that's the thing that's a
thing and I think part of the reason why
I've like taken a step back from going
out so much is because like I'll go out
till the cows come home if it's a
fabulous outing but I just feel like
lately there aren't that many fabulous
outings maybe I'm not getting invited to
Fabulous places or people are getting
less fabulous I think you get invited to
some fabulous stuff and it's kind of
sometimes disappointing I think other
times you do go to like the opening of
an envelope it's weird what you usually
choose to go to because it's just like
if you're in the mood to go out and I
used to do this all the time too when in
my Heyday it's like well I'm going out
tonight so whatever's happening is where
I'm going but it's like oh tonight
really a great night like no it's like
my my personal Vibe doesn't always match
up with my schedule yes agreed yeah
that's so true I feel it but this
weekend it did for you yeah no it was
great I feel tired but I feel you know I
feel like a socialite and
that's special that is special I'm happy
for you how was your weekend my weekend
was just really tiring just on mom duty
like all weekend never got out of my
pajamas uh sounds amazing I well it was
like it was a lot of work to have a sick
one little one but he was he was good in
Sweden it just meant a lot of naps on
Mom which meant a lot of reading time
for Mom oh that's good so it was good
and I was able to stick to my diet and
I'm happy for that
yes I'm very excited so now I'm like a
week into eating really really well
healthy uh diet that I'm doing is just
like obviously you know not indulging
but low sodium to no sodium if you can
do it it's really hard uh
no oil no butter no sugar that is the
plan that you were that's okay right
that's a plan you were put on when you
went on your retreat when everyone
thought you were like uh pregnant and in
rehab or in rehab for uh for alcohol
yeah right but you were just lowering
your sodium intake I was lowering I was
in rehab for I was overdose sodium yeah
so that's the predicin lifestyle if you
can do it it's hard to like find things
to eat like because there aren't
everything has sodium in it look at the
back of every nutrition products look at
the back sodium through the roof so it's
hard to get to zero sodium and that's
not even possible really
but it makes everything like less tasty
but you can eat a lot of really good
nutrient dense foods and not be super
hungry it's just kind of bland and
boring
yeah it actually sounds like a diet I
would like because like oh it has no
flavor give it to me yeah and you can
eat a lot of brown rice
and you can eat potatoes potatoes but
just like boiled or baked with no oil no
butter no cheese no sour actually you
could have that free sour cream what
about butter no butter you could
margarine no margarine you could maybe
Spritz it like once with I Can't Believe
It's Not Butter spray you know let's
talk about I Can't Believe It's Not
Butter spray I'm so glad you brought it
up because honestly I Can't Believe It's
Not Butter like I can it tastes like
chemical crack it's so good literally
like that is one of probably I think
when like years from now when somebody's
studying like toxic diet culture the
rise like in the early 2000s like
I Can't Believe It's Not Butter spray is
the Cornerstone product of the toxic
diet culture and I love it so much I
think it's so good I put that [ __ ] on
everything popcorn rice cakes like I
think it's better than real butter
because it's like good luck spreading
butter you know because it's spritzable
good luck spreading butter seriously I
think that it's a miracle product and I
love it and I I really I cannot Believe
It's Not Butter Zach puts it on
everything too I think it's so good you
should only use a few spritzes when you
do you barely taste it and if you use
more spritzes then it defeats the
purpose of it being a low calorie
product and do you know why I really
like it because it's fully made of
chemicals there's no food in it like you
could literally buy one and keep it in
your fridge for five years and it would
never expire because it's fully other
one in my kitchen I think I got when I
moved in yeah it's pretty scary Zach
likes it so much that the butter that he
like spreadable butter he buys I Can't
Believe It's Not Butter brand
I completely agree it's a brand I can
trust I love this honestly I have to
make the tick tock I love this man and I
would do anything I love that butter so
much you know what better I like what
breakstone
you know what butter I actually think is
like the best butter
it's like the little packets like of
like french butter that you get at like
restaurants like those are really yeah
if you hold it over a candle you can
melt it I love a little salt in my
butter Butter's so good I can't have any
of those things right now but it's fun
talking about it
no I bet it's like so fun but I can have
oatmeal
yum
tell me about that I can have oatmeal
with estebia and some cinnamon oh crazy
girl
oatmeal is actually great because it's
really filling and it's zero sodium
like it's not gonna be like the tastiest
thing but when you'll at least feel full
when you're done yeah move on with your
day and not like be thinking about like
food for that there's just like you know
what I'm thinking about like there are
so many like Brands I Can't Believe It's
Not Butter is one of them that like
really were a part of like that rise of
like Diet products like and I think
about like ones we had in our house like
I consider like in the same category
like Cream of Wheat and like Fig Newtons
yeah cream of wheat is an interesting
product good luck making Cream of Wheat
correctly because you'll never [ __ ]
do it and what is it and what is the
right consistency okay so the brand is
cream of wheat the product the product
is it's not grits and it's not oatmeal
it's like somewhere in between it's
literally creamy wheat
creme de la wheat it's creme de la wheat
yeah it's just such a good question like
what is it
I don't know
it's like porridge it's porridge for
sure right yeah
um so that's a type
that's the toxic diet culture segment of
today's show it's about a great diet
that Imani is not toxic whatsoever it
encourages you to eat a lot just of
nutrient-dense foods so veggies protein
and then whole grains brown rice legumes
if you want pasta whole wheat pasta if
I'm at like a wedding that has like
different sections of catered food like
you will find me at the Lagoon station
you know will you
legume yeah it's like beans rice
beef oh
it's not like lentils no I think uh well
lentils actually won so pretty and
approved
um oh thank God but legumes are beans
I don't mind a lentil
lentils are
I like lentils
I like your rental
I like your uncle
who doesn't
um okay we have five stories and I want
to get into them because I need to talk
about House of the Dragon like I it's
time not two of the Big D
House of the day House of the Demons
literally so I say we dive in let's dive
in I also need to talk about the queen
like I'll be talking about the queen I
think you can guarantee I'll be having
one like Royal update story till the end
of September
um wow because like right now she's
driving through the country to everyone
she hasn't been laid to rest yet no so
then like be talking about her till the
funeral and then obviously the funeral
is going to be a big deal so um just get
ready and I'm gonna keep talking about
her because I miss her so you know this
is our first Monday without the queen
and it doesn't get easier no and you
could feel it too it's in the air
totally so without further Ado here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by the
Clinique Even Better clinical dark spot
interrupter if you have dark spots it
can often feel like a vicious cycle as
soon as one Fades another one pops up so
break the cycle with the Clinique Even
Better clinical dark spot interrupter
this powerful serum works on melon and
Rich to fair skin and it helps visibly
correct dark spots such as acne marks
while protecting from future
discoloration 94 of people demonstrated
an improvement in Radiance and visible
tone including acne marks in just eight
weeks you can see a 39 visible reduction
in dark spots in almost 12 weeks if you
have dark spots I get them during the
summer a lot you know how unbelievably
difficult they are to get rid of and
like once you do boom another one so I
really like this Clinique product I feel
like Clinique is a brand you can really
trust I think they've been around for a
long time it's a trustworthy brand and
there's effective
effects because like I said 94 of people
demonstrated an improvement and it's
developed by dermatologists which is
also fabulous so you can get the even
better clinical dark spot interrupter
today it's available at clinique.com
that's the even better clinical dark
spot interrupter available at
clinique.com today's episode is also
brought to you by thumba
let me buildum
you're through a bed literally arrived a
few weeks ago right right a few weeks
ago yes it's in snitch's room and I
assembled it so easy to assemble like I
know a lot of people probably seen the
targeted ads for thuma because we talk
about it too much and your phone is
listening to you so much you'll see the
ads today and they're like their whole
thing aside from being like gorgeous and
wonderful Furniture is that a lay person
can put it together and I'm here to tell
you that truly a lay person can put it
together which is huge for big furniture
it's huge because it could be so
frustrating to be setting up a bed or
really any piece of furniture that
doesn't have you in mind and the bed by
thuma is handcrafted from eco-friendly
high quality upcycled wood and you'll
find beautiful unique variations in
natural grains the design is very
minimalist it features Japanese joinery
and it helps Elevate any space very
supportive for your mattress it's
breathable and it's made to naturally
minimize noise and create space it's
made for how you live so it's backed
with a lifetime warranty it ships right
to your door in three easy boxes and it
takes about five minutes to assemble
with no no tools required
along with the bed thuma also offers
other Essentials for the bedroom like
the mattress the nightstand and the side
table and they all perfectly complement
the bed they also work with one tree
planted so they plant one tree for every
bed and nightstand sold all of their
Essentials are green guard gold
certified as well create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma and now go to thuma.co toast to
receive a 25 credit towards your
purchase of the bed plus free shipping
in the continental US go to thuma.co
toast that's t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash
toast for 25 credit
great okay our first story
Queen update segment first news of
Queen's funeral details have been
revealed so for everybody who's curious
here's what's in store for all of us the
state funeral of her majesty the queen
will take place at Westminster Abbey on
Monday September 19th at 1100 hours BST
so I think that's British central time
yeah no no so if it's 11 o'clock there
11 o'clock A.M I think we're five or six
hours behind which would make it five or
six a.m the thing about like being an
American obsessed with the Royals is
they love a mid-morning Affair and like
when I was in high school I was so
obsessed with William and Kate's wedding
that I actually woke up at five in the
morning to watch and I was allowed to
not go to school like I was obsessed but
it's low-key [ __ ] annoying it is but
you know what Harry does have a wake up
around five to six a.m I usually go back
to sleep after it but maybe on September
19th I'll just what if I just says
yeah shout out to the Sky News Apple TV
app because trying to get news from
another country is low-key not easy no
low-key
Loki no bueno drink every time Claudia
says hello Loki
it's I'm So Young it's hella low-key
brev
okay prior to the state funeral though
Queen's still on her as Charles said her
last journey prior to the state funeral
the queen will lie in state in
Westminster hall for four days to allow
the public to pay their respects
according to the Palace the Queen's
coffin is currently resting in the
ballroom at Balmoral Castle and will
travin travel to Edinburgh on Sunday it
will then rest in the throne room at the
palace of Hollywood house until Monday
afternoon so right now she is at
hollyrod house
no it says she said about moral that was
on Sunday this was oh okay it's just so
you know it's interesting how people's
Customs are so different because for me
most of the funerals I've been to have
been Jewish funerals
um and they literally happen like they
would have had a funeral on Friday like
the day after Queenie passed away
because that's just our custom so it
feels so weird to like have a body be
chilling like for multiple weeks how do
they keep the body from you know like
decaying embalm
formaldehyde yeah
it's so crazy so crazy people will be
able to go and pay their respects that's
nice which is really nice and then so
September 19th is a Monday okay so in a
week
oh September 19th yes I'll be traveling
Oh you know what I might be up super
early too wait I'm gonna be on Pacific
Time so what does that mean because I'm
being three hours traveling that means
two three A.M
[ __ ] okay so I'm gonna be traveling from
Seattle because I have shows in Portland
and Seattle this weekend come see me
girl with nojob.com tour we've got a few
tickets left to both shows again
Portland and Seattle this is my one and
only trip on the tour to the Pacific
Northwest and I would love to see you
there
um
usually the conversation
flows it did flow naturally I am going
to be in Pacific time because I'm on
tour tickets available at girls no
job.com tour I don't know what you want
me to say I think the queen respects
Moguls I think the queen would want you
to promote your tour
100 she's like literally the definition
of a woman who supports other women yeah
and well she and I don't have that in
common oh and Mogul yeah she would
totally I don't feel like that was
insensitive no no no no I don't think so
and I've been seeing some hella
insensitive things about the queen
online so like oh my God yeah there's
all these people who are just so nasty
yeah like making jokes like someone died
no and jokes is the least of it
yeah
um
so I guess I will not be able to catch
the funeral
well I'm sure there will be replays and
highlight reels and we'll get you know
content but I do want to watch it live
to to be a part of it and to pay my
respects because right now I feel like
I'm in a state of denial I I was
watching Platinum Jubilee yesterday
which was just like take me back to
platinum Jubilee you know it was an
amazing day I wanted to be platinum
Jubilee every day every day like I was
re-watching the concert and I was just
like loving life
yeah do you think that like this is
going to be a type of Royal event like
with like you know how like every time
there's like a royal wedding or
something like we get the celebs who go
it's usually like the beckhams it's
always like guy Richie Elton John I
Felix Serena Williams like Oprah
um is like are do the presidents go like
oh I don't know I feel like to a degree
it'll be like who's there I
I think it'll more so be like the Elton
John's
not
feeling Joe Biden he's not gonna be
there oh that I don't that I don't know
if if heads and like the Obamas and
Trump like they all met her I don't know
I don't know heads of state yes of State
yeah
I don't know
we'll see we've never been alive for
something like this for like a big Royal
Funeral yeah
I feel like literally every world leader
go like definitely every world leader of
countries in the Commonwealth yeah
probably goes and that's like the Geneva
Convention it'll be gonna be like more
of that less of celebrity celebrity yeah
I think so too especially because a lot
of the celebrities they got Real
Weddings were friends of the kids Megan
friends and Friends of like William
Harry whatever
um whereas this is probably like the
Queen's Associates
her Associates yeah
but it will be interesting to see who
goes and so will there be speeches from
people like in her personal life like
will we get to know more like an insight
into queeny's personality
I don't know what she has planned for us
because I've ended up on the side of
tick tock where it's like you know times
where
Queen Elizabeth was caught on camera
being funny um and she was an extremely
funny person there's like many moments
she did like little clips for the
Invictus games she to clips for like
Britain in the Olympics she did a little
clip with Bond
um
Paddington she's like a funny girl so I
would love to get to know more about her
really yeah I think there'll probably be
some eulogies
you think Charles I
I don't know I don't know if this
information is even out there yet and I
just haven't seen it or or like what the
protocol is for Royal funerals I'm not
familiar I'm not familiar but also I do
believe like she had a plan
for all of this like she worked on the
plan so it's whatever she wanted which
is nice to know it which is nice yeah
but I do think the concepts that
planning on your own funeral the only
reference we have is Prince Philip
do you think there was like speeches
it wasn't as star studded but it was
also more covety
yeah the concept of like being alive and
planning your own funeral is so bizarre
yeah
well yeah
but I'm glad that she did like it's
bizarre for Lay people I think but for
the queen like
we want to do it your way yeah yeah 100
whatever the queen wants we respect her
wishes yeah so that'll be on Monday a
week from today and the other Royal news
that everybody is a flutter about is
that The Fab Four we're back together in
name only really but you know everyone
will name only William I'm sorry Prince
and Princess of Wales and the former
Duke and Duchess of Sussex Kate William
Megan and Harry were walking through
Windsor Castle together looking at the
tributes to Gran and the world is
quaking that the four of them were doing
something together okay it was like so
crazy to see them together and like part
of me was like so upset because like in
another world like they really could
have been like this fabulous Dynamic
foursome like if Megan and Kate had
gotten along and like Harry and
William's friendship wasn't fractured
like this it would have been just like
an iconic it was like it was something
we never got like this group of the four
of them there could be so many iconic
pictures like we almost got there
remember when like Kate and Megan went
to Wimbledon but like the pick pictures
were sad like they both looked miserable
like we never got like a fabulous four
moment out of them and we could have
because they're Brothers like I just it
made me really sad they're Brothers
they're Brothers
it made me really sad that was my first
like observation my second observation
was like Megan looked so
scared like if there's so much footage
of her like actually like looking like
she'd rather be anywhere else and I
don't know if that's because she was sad
over Grand she was uncomfortable around
William Kate she was just having
flashbacks to like the terrible times
she had while in the royal family she
just looked like completely like she
would rather be literally anywhere else
yeah people are there's a lot of body
language experts on the case here I just
have to say like I don't think anything
that we saw like was an accident I don't
think anybody like slipped a lot of
people are like William and Kate aren't
touching holding hands and Megan and
Harry are holding hands well uh from
what I understand like members of the
royal family can't really do like public
displays of affection I don't think like
William and Kate hold hands but like I
don't think that they were caught not
holding hands you know yeah no that
doesn't
um also Megan is American no and they're
not Royal anymore no for sure for sure
but it's also like a cultural thing like
British people are not very like PDA
affectionate and like Americans are yeah
so even from that perspective like that
doesn't make me think that Harry and
Megan are more in love and William and
Kate are hey that's what people's take
away also there was like with the car
door William was like okay get the door
yes okay
people aren't wrong about that because I
was watching this live on Sky News the
Apple TV app and I was like of course
like Harry's literally like
tucking her into the car and William's
like get in the front seat [ __ ] like it
was so different shotgun no literally
but also like that's like Ben has
literally never opened the door for me
if that's being married for two years
versus being married for 10. for sure
but if the eyes of the world were
watching would you know Ben wouldn't
think Ben doesn't Ben doesn't think like
people are gonna know how much I love my
wife if I open the door he's like I know
how much I love my wife and she can get
her fat ass in the car like I like but I
thought that was funny because like as a
girl whose husband I think like worships
me never has once opened the [ __ ] car
door uh literally he would let the door
swing and hit me in the face before he
opened it for me like he doesn't think
of that right and also there's this
weird dynamic where like Kate I don't
think can walk in front of William yes
walking behind him which like in is
dismissive looking yeah in modern
relationships it's not a thing that you
do yeah so like we're coming at it like
in the tabloids from our American
perspective when she's doing everything
right like literally if she meets
someone and like will is walking over
she's not allowed to shake their hand
before William does right right so
there's just like things that make it
look socially awkward but it totally is
protocol but now that Megan and Harry
don't have to do that like they can be
themselves and be more comfortable and
like be more intimate so people are
gonna juxtapose that against William and
Kate who look like they hate each other
but they're just following protocol yeah
and I feel like William Kate has
definitely had like a a bit of a rough
patch in the last couple of years in
their marriage I think that there was a
lot of rumors
um about you know a friend of Kate's
coming between them
perhaps some infidelity
um and seeing them out and about I feel
like you know times like this grief and
loss like that's what brings families
back together that's what heals
marriages and I think they've been good
for a while though I feel like those I
think they're getting better years ago
and I feel like they've been pretty
strong for a while and I also think they
could learn a lot for and they probably
have learned a lot from Queenie and
Prince Philip yes who you know maybe
there's something similar maybe if they
weren't the queen and the prince they
wouldn't have stayed together but for
Duty they had to and like now we regard
their relationship as a you know not a
fairy tale I want to say but a model an
institution and it wasn't without hard
work and and pain
hundred percent and like they're
morphing into that yeah but so but when
you're gonna be compared to like this
you know newlywed world with American
and also Megan and Harry are very
into like touchy feely and just I feel
like they just because also maybe
because like it's
they've cut out a lot of other people in
their life like they're very much like
us against the world they're insular
like yeah they lean on each other yes
because they mostly have each other but
I just I do want to say like in terms of
a marriage like I definitely identify
more with William and Kate because like
if me and Ben are around other couples
like and you're just gonna compare us
like we're not the ones like groping
like we're the ones just like eating and
laughing you know yeah
yeah
uh if I'm wearing heels I'm probably
leaning on to my husband that doesn't
count that's okay so if we're in this
situation like we're we're linked arms
you know like if we're like out to
dinner like yeah I'm gonna check my
phone and it doesn't mean I don't love
my husband yeah because I'm not holding
his hand across the table do you know
how uncomfortable that is my arms are
short like I also think for William and
Kate like this they're meeting the the
people who love them who are like there
to support them and like show love and I
think for Harry and Megan like they
didn't know what they were going to
receive consider yes the way that
they've left the UK and like you know
it's so interesting how like
what we think of the situation because
we're totally Outsiders like our like
the American perspective is like Harry
and Megan are like heroic in how they
left and the British perspective is like
very anti-megan and Harry like they they
took it personal when they left so I
imagine going back there it's not like
doing a meet and greet in New York like
it sucks yeah and you don't know if
someone's literally gonna like throw a
drink in your face and they're I don't
know if you saw the clip like of a woman
who was standing at the barricades there
were two sides of the road filled with
barricades William and Kate went to one
side and Megan and Harry went to the
other so like you knew which Royal you
were going to meet and it was clear that
this one woman on Harry and Megan's side
like she wanted to be on William and
Kate's side but they chose the other
side and she literally like did not
shake her hand did not look her in the
eyes and it was truly like so painful
and awkward I actually like I felt
really bad for Megan
that's so awkward it was hard but like
the woman is like she has her chin in
her hand she's just like looking
straight ahead like I I totally get like
not liking a celebrity like okay let's
say I don't like
um
who do I do I okay Charlie puth
um but he like comes up to me at a party
and wants to meet like of course like
hey Charlie I love your song like I'm
fake and I'm a loser so honestly to like
keep your scrupled hate while meeting
the person like that's brave because
celebrities are just like intimidating
and she is this Duchess she's like this
worldwide Global phenomenon sort of
really stub her like that was crazy
yes I think the circumstances are just a
little different though in the sense
that like the people who went to the
gates of Windsor like loved the queen
immensely like so many people love the
queen like we love her but like do you
see me at Windsor no like we don't we
don't know her the people who are like
standing outside the gates like leaving
those tributes are the Queen's number
one fans and I think that those people
saw the way everything went down and
imagine how much that might have hurt
the queen and and they're there for the
queen so yeah I think she felt prop this
woman probably felt very principled
about not saying hi overall like I got
no joy from watching the four of them
like looking miserable together no
because it really highlighted like what
we got versus what we could have gotten
like if the four of them had just worked
it out whatever it was like I still
don't even really know like what the
beef between her and Kate was but
if they had been able to like become
like it would have been historic like
yeah they're both they're all four of
them are so fabulous and like stylish
and I just imagined what we could have
gotten and if it had worked out and that
makes me sad it does make me sad and I
did not get any Joy because I just could
feel all the tension stiff all the
performative like this is theater and
you're they're like looking at each
other and they're not actors except for
one right and they're like looking at
they're pointing at little flowers like
oh look at that like what look it's
literally like how could you actually
read anything when you know that
everyone is watching and evaluating
every move that you're making yeah I
will say before they waved and got into
the cars
um
like you I don't know if you've seen
this clip like Megan looks like she
wants to die like literally she looks
like a robot she looks like she's about
to cry actually it was really sad and
I'm curious what was going through her
mind is it you know I'm sad for Gran is
it I don't want to be here I hate these
people like what is it you know I didn't
see that that was after that you have to
watch after the meet and greets so they
look they look at the flowers oh they
Point look is that cool and they walk
over them barricades then they walk up
the barricades to their cars and then
they wave one last time before getting
in the car and she literally is on the
verge of tears maybe it was that woman
who who snubbed her maybe she was
getting an energy from other fans of
like maybe it was just like a miserable
experience like all of it not just one
specific moment yeah oh I gotta tell you
the clip yeah I'll send it to you like
that's a good thing about being on Queen
talk like you don't miss a thing I know
but you've been sending me some Queen
talks my new issue with Tick Tock they
make it so hard for people who don't
have the app to enjoy a morsel of tick
tock the new new thing is like the way
people put their captions it's too high
for those of us who are viewing on
Safari because they like have this Tick
Tock brand that drops down so low okay
sorry that makes sense like they're a
business and you have like if you want
to engage that's like that's literally
like watching the toast but not
subscribing like why just [ __ ]
subscribe no but you can still watch
your toast have a premium experience
even if you don't subscribe like we
would never maybe that's why we're not
as big as Tick Tock maybe that's why
we're not as big as them for sure but I
just feel like in my heart it's the
right thing to do to give people that
joy for without 100 without asking for
anything in return because we're Moguls
with a heart
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
okay so that's the update for the day
anything else that struck you this
weekend from our friends across the pond
I don't think so but I'll let you know
okay thank you
you're welcome you are welcome now all
the biggest stars in the UK were doing
that the biggest stars here we're at
Beyonce's 41st birthday party yeah they
were
so lots of celebs were seen entering and
exiting Beyonce's star-studded birthday
bash in Bel Air California
including Kim Kardashian Khloe
Kardashian Tristan Thompson
Kris Jenner and Corey Gamble as well I
obviously like it's a cool party the
Kardashians go but I think that there's
been so many like rumors about what
Beyonce thinks about Kim
um and at first it was like Jay-Z it was
literally like The Fab Four and it for
like a minute it was good you know and
then it was not things obviously got bad
between Jay-Z and Kanye there were a lot
of rumors that Beyonce did not like him
he thought she thought that Kim was like
tacky
um but then recently like
you know Beyonce sends Ivy Park to Kim
like they support one another you know
Beyonce does that thing where she wishes
celebrities happy birthday on her
website with like a picture of them as a
child and she does it for all the
Kardashian girls like she even does it
for Courtney like so it seems like their
relationship is like a fine I don't know
if it was at the level where you know
she would invite her to her birthday
party but she did and that makes me
really happy because
Kim like I feel like
I think Kim puts a lot of shock in what
like people like Beyonce think about her
you know because for so long she was
like that reality star sex tape girl
she's like worked so hard to get out of
that so to be invited to Beyonce's
birthday party is like it's a validating
thing I think yeah definitely it's not
like so surprising to me I feel like
where doesn't Kim get invited except
Buckingham Palace for the right for the
Jubilee uh and now I don't know if that
was true but I'm sure she even wishes
more so now that she that she was able
to score an invite yeah I thought it was
nice that Chloe was there a lot of
people were like Tristan I think Tristan
was literally someone's plus one like I
don't think he got invited by Beyonce I
think he was strikes plus one I think
him and Drake are friends like he wasn't
you know he didn't get you know Mr
Tristan Thompson address and you know I
think it was Chloe's plus one no you
don't think they're better together no
they didn't arrive together no also
machine gun and Megan Fox were there
looking really that was surprising
really great yeah surprising too which
one do you think was on the invitation
which one was the Megan you think
yeah what's a relationship
there's not a relationship but Megan's
just been around in Hollywood and like
been A-list for so long like those are
the types of relationships you make and
I think her and Beyonce are probably
around the same age
41 would be the age
yeah that tracks for both of them okay
yeah lizzo was also there Lily Rose Depp
Vanessa Bryant Jay-Z random oh no I'm
sorry they said Vanessa Bayer sorry
no so rich Paul and Adele yes
I think they look fabulous roller disco
yeah it did look fabulous everyone was
showing up and showing out and I'm glad
they had a good time that's a party like
a dead ass have fomo from like let me go
please but at least you had a fun
weekend in your own right
for sure but not as fun as theirs really
not that it's a competition no no but
like it could have easily been like one
of those parties that has all the
makings of a great for sure for shoes
off
I don't know I just feel like people
like put their energy on
high alert for Beyonce's party I I agree
with that I don't think the energy was
off I'm just saying like there's a
chance it could have been did you see a
photo of Beyonce because I didn't no
well I think it was at her house so she
never had to leave and she never had to
come in oh fabulous yeah
I'm just really happy Kim was there like
that wouldn't have been a given oh also
speaking of the Kardashians we finally
got yep that's our next story oh okay
business news from Courtney we know what
Lenny is so this morning Courtney
dropped all the details about Lemmy I'm
gonna read it from her Instagram caption
because there's a lot of information and
that information basically says Claudia
that's right that's the headline here
Claudia was right she said let me
finally share what I've been up to I've
been dreaming of this idea having lots
and lots and lots of meetings and
conversations with different people
trying to figure out the best way to
build this the right partners and
building the team that felt really good
when it was finally all right it was all
happening with ease lots of hours zoom's
dreaming but all with swift decisiveness
and actual fun at last five years later
my passion work baby is finally
launching into the world meet Lemmy my
new line of vitamins and supplements
that I created to become a Divine feel
good part of your everyday life we
partner with the best scientists in
doctor to create the cleanest gummy
vitamins and supplements using
clinically backed ingredients and
formulations that help you live your
best life so I was right things in which
to live and of course we made them so
delicious you won't believe they're good
for you we launch on September 27 2022
exclusively on let me live.com
so
um one I was right
two uh this is not surprising this is
super on brand for Courtney I think it's
more on brand than being a boohoo with
sustainability Ambassador like this is
this feels right that's why like it's a
good thing like I was able to guess it
do you know what I mean like because
that means it makes sense for her right
um I will say though that this is like a
really saturated space
um with Brands like that are like
influencer backed like you know there's
Ollie there's ritual goop has
um so I just find I think it's gonna be
hard right
vital proteins tati sugar bear like
there are a lot of gummy
um companies that are all like clean
non-GMO like they're all kinds of Dunes
right big competitor so I do think it's
going to be hard to enter the space kind
of late and make a real impact but
that's what the Kardashian brands do so
that remains to be seen
I think The Branding is really cool
um but I I do think what you said last
week is really on point like why
wouldn't this be a push brand yeah I was
just thinking that that because this
could be push
DTC like you know push finally has like
a product and not a conceptual episode I
feel like no shade to push but I I feel
like one it's not that like massive or
anything not like a brand that you have
to capitalize on and two I don't know
that the name like outside of their
Circle and I know that like Courtney is
pushing they call Pee push like I feel
like the name never really hit but like
the way I think about Lemmy already I'm
like that's a [ __ ] brilliant name the
concept the the names of the vitamins
let me just let me just read some of
them
um
where is it
yeah I agree and making it like it's a
separate brand they had like a whole
separate launch for it yeah new
Instagram it's more exciting they have
de-stress gummies called Lemmy chill
they have
um concentration gummies called
lemifocus and then energy B12 gummies
called Lemmy matcha so like I feel like
there are so many more opportunities for
Branding and whatnot wears I don't think
the push brand ever went past like that
initial Wellness quality yeah that like
very Niche audience
yeah no I think that's totally fair and
I agree that like it's more of a moment
because it's its own brand with like
really great graphics and logos but I do
think like she has a challenge in terms
of differentiating yourself because
all these gum like personally I use
Ollie vitamins I take the hair and nails
and I also do the uh
melatonin ones
um and they have cute names like it's
it's just like a it's a saturated space
I agree but I will say um and I don't I
don't currently take any gummies but
when it comes to like wellness and what
you put in your body and all of that
like I actually would trust Courtney
like Shame about that life you know and
she's been walking the walk like before
it was cool yeah and I believe her when
she says it's been five years and like
looking for the right partners and like
I
I would trust her on this because she's
so true she's so about it and like
militant about it she's been that way on
the show for so many years and I I think
it would like go against everything she
believes in to put in something put out
something that like doesn't check all
those boxes for her that's super true I
I'm curious though if like when she left
that um comment on Instagram saying she
was on the phone with her attorneys
working on seven business deals if this
was one of them it could have been like
okay this the boohoo sustainability you
know at the time a few years ago she did
like a pretty little thing collab then
there was push then like push X goop
push your Wellness virtual Retreat and
number seven
um they had a day camp remember push day
camp Oh that was that was really cute it
was like an influencer thing but it was
cute yeah yeah seven business deals you
love to see them
so let me live I love it I think it's
genius
um
and agreed it's great that like you were
able to guess it if she ever wants to
come out with non-toxic cookware like
I'm open because I love my Caraway so
much that like
I would get more far away maybe they'll
Branch out like yeah I think you know
assuming this is good and it looks like
the logo that swirl she in the promo
picture she's like laying in like a ball
pit of Swirls and I guess that's what
the gummies are gonna be like
cute that's really cute yeah they look
like Smarties yeah I think it's all
really great I'm really happy for her
it's to see yeah Courtney no and like
she really needs to post that clip in
the back of the car where she's fighting
with Kim about the Candyland themed
birthday like how can you have a Candy
Land with no [ __ ] candy you're
wearing leather shoes plastic glasses we
need that yeah also subset B of
Kardashian business ventures Kylie is
launching a new series on her YouTube
channel called Kylie's Glam Bar where
she'll be like interviewing people at
like a Glam pink oh in her Studio giving
it's giving Haley Bieber welcome to my
bathroom that's exactly what it is but
it's also good because she has this huge
YouTube channel she puts out one video
every six months
um now we'll have some like regularity
with the content and we'll get to see
more of Kylie's personality which I love
she's been like so low-key like she has
to come back like I know she had a baby
and I respected
she's been back for like since London
she's doing everything she's doing the
press this and that Kendall was on a
podcast today by the way did you see
this yes Jay Shetty Jackie he's the one
who married to Joe
very cool so I feel like Kylie is in
Mogul mode and I love this idea for our
YouTube channel
I love it too I love the Kardashians
embracing podcasting I feel like
um a lot of Chloe's anxieties that she
talked about like about interviews and
stuff really I think exists when it
comes to traditional media because it's
like so old school and like it's not
those aren't even her fans watching it's
like people like old people I feel like
them embracing podcasting is first of
all so good for them because they really
get an opportunity to like
speak for a long period of time and like
really say how they feel and like not be
like a dumb clip on Jimmy Fallon
um and people are very receptive like I
feel like a lot of people once they
watch like a long form interview of
anyone but like specifically a
Kardashian they always leave with like
more respect for them you know yeah even
if they didn't start out liking them so
I feel like the platform like the medium
is really good for them and I love to
see them doing more podcasts like it's
everything it's a great medium I mean we
can't say enough good things about it I
think it's really a wonderful space
and I've enjoyed my time in the space
and of course like if Kylie 2 wants to
venture into podcasting like there's no
place safer for you than here at the
morning toast we will literally you know
like eat your duty anything you want
are you ready for our next story yeah
Leah Michelle is devastated to skip
funny girl due to covid-19 symptoms and
confirmed covet at this point okay like
not me literally putting this in the
universe did you say this what'd you say
remember I told you that the toasters
played a prank on me when I was on
Instagram live like getting ready for
funny girl then they write oh my God
Claudia Alias coven and now she does
oh this sucks like not to be rude but
like who gets covered like where the
[ __ ] have you been hanging out like the
whole like so much of the cast has it
apparently like there's a lot of like a
crazy outbreak yeah I swear to God like
I don't know anyone like personally who
has gotten coveted in the last like year
like no like people are still getting
covered
still going around but it's just I think
the way that we like think about and
deal with it now is just like it's like
different yeah it's not like you have to
like shut down like you know right put
into a remote island your house like
going to a quarantine Camp it's like
yeah okay get well soon we'll see you
soon yes see you soon girly I'll send
you some soup text me when you're
feeling better by the way this sucks but
like it also kind of rocks for Lea
Michelle like you know easing back into
Broadway is not easy like she did a
Monday show a two no she did a Tuesday
show two Wednesday shows and like it's
very physically exhausting so to get
like a week off and like be with your
kid like kind of rocks I don't know but
she had like all this momentum don't you
feel like I would I would agree with
that like in a few months like yay I get
you know a week off but yeah a lot of
momentum so much momentum and it's like
the plot of this storyline like keeps
getting thicker like it just it's the
craziest Saga how like art was imitating
life and then life was imitating art and
now it just like keeps going and people
what sucks is like the you know people
Rosie O'Donnell literally tweeted no I'm
flying in next week like people are
flying in like yeah that's who it really
sucks for like the ticket holder the
people there to see Leah apparently her
understanding is amazing so Julie benko
was the understudy for Beanie and beanie
like half the time didn't show up and
people [ __ ] love Julie Banco she's
like a really authentic to the role
she's Jewish she speaks Yiddish like
she's amazing and when beanie dipped out
early before Leah was set to start Julie
was not the understudy she was the main
girly for like an entire month and
people loved her Ben's parents are said
she was amazing I'm sure she's great but
if you're buying the tickets you're
doing it because of all the Fanfare from
Leah yeah
I follow this girl on Tick Tock like if
you know you know they're like she tells
you like crazy facts like about like
business and like
like customer service and she like does
these little skits so she'll like she'll
be like pretending to talk to the
cashier well I know that you know Nike
has to give me my shoes back my money
back if my shoes don't blah blah blah
and the cashier is like fine how did you
know that and she goes because I follow
Erica she reads the tips the terms
the terms and conditions so you don't
have to that's why I follow her she's
this girl Erica and you know what I've
learned so much from her like little
things like about how companies like
have to give you your money back like
and on Broadway I think I learned this
from Erica like if you get tickets in
the understudy like you can get your
money back just saying oh don't do it I
understand but this girl Erica so ever
like Shapiro loves her he's like do you
know Erica and he like repeated her
signature like sign off in her videos
she's like that's why I follow Erica she
reads the terms and conditions she's a
lawyer and he loves her and I was in a
taxi and I saw taxi TV commercial she
bought like ad space for her Tick Tock I
thought that was so smart I'm gonna do
that
that is really smart now we should do it
for the toast no offense
we've actually always said like we don't
do any marketing like we couldn't hurt
like you know uh spend a little money on
some like marketing some Billboards in
your taxi TV I think we could just play
like a little Sizzle reel of us being
cute and funny yeah I think we need
billboards
yeah I've every time we talk about this
like I get reached out to by like a
million toasters who work in like out of
what's it called out of home uh uh Clear
Channel outdoor voice yeah one of those
um and like I've uh like five times I've
taken it all the way we make like
mock-ups and then I get to price and I'm
like no one cares about us why are we
spending like so much money on like
subway ads and billboards in Times
Square like it does nothing no I think
like it does stuff but you have to have
so many and like we could really just
probably get the one yeah no like my
dream like we need to wrap for an entire
summer like a Hampton Jitney yeah just
like with our big faces and like
everyone will take pictures of it and
when they're in the city and the
Hamptons like because like our biggest
city in terms of like audience is New
York like the traffic is that not mean
that we should go to a different city
and build up our audience there like
maybe we've hit a lot of people here and
would it just be people seeing it who
already listen
yeah but like then they'll take pictures
of it like so maybe we'll dive into some
marketing but probably not it's just
something we talk about and now I'm
gonna get like a million emails um and
I'll probably like pretend to do it and
then not
yeah we prefer our Grassroots marketing
efforts uh tell a friend about the
morning toast photos my friend who you
know doesn't listen tell him phone a
friend phone a friend that's the one now
are you ready for our fifth and final
story I really am oh wait sorry yeah I
was gonna say like I totally forgot like
to work today is it the fifth and final
story that's brought to you by osia
yes it's important to prep your skin to
stay hydrated and smooth with safe clean
products and that's why OCS skincare
products help nourish soften and smooth
your skin to keep you glowing from head
to toe OCA is a brand I saw like so many
fabulous people using on social media
for so long and I finally like got with
the program and I can say like it lives
up to the hype what I really like about
them is all their products are big it's
like it's a cream you use three times
and then it goes away like no this will
last you for a long time
so if you want to maintain your radiant
Summer Skin during the fall like if you
have a tan that you want to keep
hydrated
um check out the oceans andaria algae
body oil it keeps your skin soft and
glowing with andaria algae acai pulp and
babasu seed oil it's rich and not greasy
I've been very hesitant to use body oils
because like who wants to walk around
like all slicked up but it's not greasy
at all like it really there's a really
effective nourishing feeling from it it
smells so good the container is huge
like it will last you a long time and it
just feels good to like know that it's
made with like real things from the sea
it's clean it's nourishing they also
have
um this total body glow Trio that comes
with the andaria algae body oil but it
also includes a moisturizing body scrub
and a plant-based body brush if you like
to tan
um artificially like you need to be
doing like a real routine before you're
putting on Tanner and that means
scrubbing exfoliating hydrating and this
um Trio is perfect for that you get rid
of the dead skin then hydrate for soft
glowing skin and all their products are
clean safe responsibly sourced vegan
cruelty free and powered by the Sea so
find your new skin care and Body Care
favorites at ocm malibu.com and get a
special discount just from listening to
the toast that's 10 off your first order
for site-wide from the entire site with
promo code toast at osea malibu.com you
also get free samples with every order
over and orders over fifty dollars get
free shipping so you're going to want it
all at osea malibu.com promo code toast
great our fifth and final story a little
exciting daytime news as you know fall
TV is getting underway Jennifer Hudson
and Sherry Shepard are part of the
daytime TV makeover uh new shows
debuting this week include the Jennifer
Hudson show okay wait for them generally
the lead right and then Sherry Shepard
is getting her own show called Sherry
which doesn't sound like new news
because she was filling in for Wendy and
now I think it's just Sherry and also
caramo Brown of queer eye is getting his
own show called caramo they're joining a
daytime lineup that includes continuing
talk variety series is the Kelly
Clarkson show the Drew Barrymore show
Tamron Hall and ratings leaders like The
View Dr Phil and Live with Kelly and
Ryan so
um like wait for them to not like
promote this at all like who the [ __ ]
knew I feel like when Kelly was getting
her show and then there was talks about
like who's going to take Ellen's time
slot Jennifer Hudson's name was floated
around a little bit but we never even
got confirmation that she was getting
her own show so like wait for them to
Fumble that completely no and so I saw
that uh Jennifer Hudson and Sherry
Shepard had daytime talk shows
premiering so I Googled like Jennifer
Hudson Sherry Shepard shows and every
single article is the exact same
headline it was just like a PR Wireless
but there's no details press really
around it or like different articles
like we're talking to Jennifer Hudson
it's just like everything says Jennifer
Hudson and Sherry Shepard are part of a
daytime shake-up and it's like copy
paste copy paste copy paste I do feel
like Sherry Shepard and Jennifer Hudson
are good choices
I feel like caramo is very much like the
future you know he's on a streaming
service he's very much an influencer
um and as much as you know be having
your own talk show is so cool it's not
like the thing anymore you know you can
have a YouTube channel that gets 10
times more viewers than a daytime show
and it's prestigious and it's cool and
it's old school but it's not really like
the media platform of the future and
caramel is very much like a pioneer I
agree with that but I think like when
done right it's big
it's big business like Ellen even Kelly
like is someone who's a new host but
like having so much success and like
we'll have success for years to come I
think it's so hard to get right and be
successful in the space and I think
that's why probably it's not for most
people and you can have an easier time
being successful doing something on your
own but like when it hits there's really
not many things that are bigger than
that right so odds are of these three
new shows like maybe one of them will
hit
um and who would you predict has the
best chance I think I would say Sherry
just because
she's so she's so experienced like she
was on The View she filled in for Wendy
like she's a real talk show host and
people think being a talk show host is
so easy like just sit and talk about
yourself it's actually not like it's a
per you have to sometimes I watch clips
from Kelly and I love her but I do feel
like she talks over a lot of her guests
sometimes like it's a perfect balance of
talking and listening while also being
interesting but also not too interesting
because it's not about you really so
you're just the host yeah so Sherry I
feel like is interesting and famous
enough but not to the point like where
it's overbearing and I feel like
Jennifer Hudson is like this worldwide
Talent she's like an Oscar winner I I
think it might be hard not to make it
about her
yeah but you would be surprised it's
crazy who is successful and who isn't I
feel like over the years we'll meet a
celebrity and we're like oh my God
they're so funny they're so great they
should have a talk show Bethany Kris
Jenner Tyra even though Tyra's show went
well it's a success but like it's not
Ellen right right so
I I can name a lot of things that
contribute to being a successful daytime
talk show host but there is that one
thing that separates the Ellens
of the world from from the felons 100
okay but so if you had to put your money
on one of these three
I don't know I I feel like it could be
Jennifer Hudson No I would say Sherry
Karama then Jennifer Hudson
I would do Jennifer Hudson Sherry caramo
yeah because what he does on queer eye
he's kind of like the he's technically
like the culture he's like the insides
coach like everybody's working on the
outside and he's working on the internet
he's like the therapist yeah and he's
like the confidence coach too right yeah
um not my favorite scene no not my
favorite segments no that's so true like
because for when you're watching a
makeover show like you want to see the
makeover and you can't see someone's
insides being made over no but like it's
you could have an interesting
conversations with people like how'd you
get to this place like what are you
about what you know and it's just like
never really did it for me yeah
um I'm sorry can we please talk about
House of the Dragon like I think of
nothing else no that was the story
anyway some Daytime shake-ups let us
know who you'll be listening to sound
off in the comments make your
predictions who's going who's going all
the way okay
House of the Dragon episode whatever
last night like I like I needed that
like I was obsessed and I know I've been
like joking about like how obsessed I am
with this like level of incest but
yesterday it just like truly came to a
head for me like just seeing them kiss
so when she went into her room the
episode had like a spooky element
because I was like oh my God someone's
in her room me and Ben were like who's
gonna kill raniera like they had like
and I didn't know what we were looking
at and I thought maybe like somebody
left a bag in there like full of like a
trick I don't know but the fact that she
got to escape and like head out with him
was like amazing except the episode had
such a fatal flaw that I couldn't get
past it
what's that the beanie they didn't have
beanies in the 1500s it wasn't a beanie
it was a beanie boy it was from Urban
Outfitters it was a full-blown beanie
oh I didn't find that to be an issue my
issue with it was like it was like a
night out in King's Landing but
everything that we've seen about King's
Landing is like horrific the people are
evil awful like murderous thievery and
it was like a lit night on the town it's
like Fashion Week in King's Landing and
it's like where's the King's Landing
that we know and that we don't love no
and honestly I feel like in the original
show there was a couple scenes where
they went to like local plays and like
saw how the people perceive them and
it's so sad and so mean like why would
you go that's like going on Reddit and
reading about yourself for sure but
Damon needed to show her why it's
important he it was a night of Education
one why it's important to make a strong
match maritally because your claim is at
risk the people don't take you seriously
they don't take you seriously and a
strong marriage will help them take you
seriously which you need to consider two
education point two marriage isn't all
bad right like we can [ __ ] and have a
good time time no like sex isn't just
about making babies right like a lot of
your friends probably told you that
because you know your bestie has to have
sex with your dad and it literally looks
like the most miserable [ __ ]
experience and that side by side of
Damon and Rainier getting it on which
literally like made my whole life I was
obsessed
spliced up with uh her friend having to
have sex with the King like that was so
sad
um and like you you know I had been like
harboring some hatred for the friend
um and in that moment like
what my hatred was unjustified because
like she didn't even want this she had
no choice and look at her life like it
sucks yeah I think the friend is fine
maybe she'll turn maybe all this misery
will turn her to be like an evil queen
but right now she really is always
looking out for a mirror like what
choice does she have her she has been
like a little condescending when she
heard that like she was [ __ ]
she was acting more like her mother
stepmother than her friend okay well
that's the role she's also in I think
sometimes she's a friend like when rainy
Oro was being like lonely moping around
the picnic yeah and sometimes she
her stepmother who needs to tell her
that like incest is not best okay wait
let's talk about that given that Allison
doesn't come from a history of incest I
think right it's unfamiliar to her let's
talk about Damon um he showed up with
short hair and it really did not bother
me I thought he was going to be very
Samson and I would like start hating him
because like his hair was really his
strength but he looked so unbelievably
hot like the way I didn't even look at
him twice when he played Prince Philip
in the crown and now I would literally
stand in front of a bus for him like
it's not normal it's not normal
um but I think that says more about
Prince Philip than it does about Matt
Smith and also Prince Philip was in his
fuckboy era right so you like hated him
the future Prince Philip actor you
probably lost yeah he's sweet pea jump
him with the one who like wants to meet
the astronauts and like takes his plate
into the right like acts nuts okay but
let's talk about the whorehouse I didn't
you know really love that he made them
you know show their yellow hair and like
be a spectacle that seemed like he
wasn't he obviously has a plan and his
plan was that like oh she'll be a [ __ ]
and no one would want to marry her and
there then I'll be the one to come save
the day you think so kind of like
because it is the perfect plan like if
everyone finds out that she's not wed
she I mean that she's not a virgin No
One's Gonna want to marry her no matter
how much you know status or money she
has and he just kind of made himself
like one of the only options
I guess I feel like for me he took off
their Garb so that like they could be
attracted to each other like when she
was dressed as like a little boy I don't
think he was gonna like start making it
over there okay that's also fair but it
did feel like because they didn't [ __ ]
because like he actually loves her and
maybe like their first time should be a
little bit more special than on the
floor of a basement of a brothel
um but he did want to like set this plan
in motion interesting you have been
right about Damon all along so I'm gonna
go with you for me Damon and Rainier are
end game because it's like they
strengthen each of their claims to the
throne little toddler can scram
and they clearly I like them both as
main characters so I like them together
but trying to get them mentally from
uncle and niece I know is you
OTP I'm struggling and when they started
making out like I was not I was freaking
out I was like happy for them but also
like this is weird how old is rhaenyra
now me and Ben 17 out yikes okay 17 and
a bunch of months going on 18. you are
16 going on
okay yes I agree like in terms of incest
like I didn't really Flinch at Jon Snow
and
because they weren't raised as auntie
and nephew they were total strangers
they got together first romantically and
then found this connection on to what
are you to do then Jamie and Cersei like
were actually twin brother and sisters
like that's next level but uncle and
auntie is right there and if I wasn't so
obsessed because he's always been her
Uncle Damon yeah
how do you look like your uncle yeah
um it doesn't honestly like maybe I'm
sick in the head it does not bother me
I'm
enthralled
but
the next big thing is like home girl
goes home her uncle got her all horny
with no climax so she takes to the next
best thing sir Kristen Cole who is so
handsome and so sweet and like really
was clearly struggling like with the
decision between his honor and his dick
um and I'm glad he went with his dick
because it was totally the right choice
I thought that was a beautiful
love-making scene what a way to lose
your virginity you know nobody gets it
like that good for you rhaenyra
but I really did not feel like they
needed us to watch her take off all of
his armor it was so painful it was so
slow I'm like you couldn't have stumbled
upon like someone with a job who doesn't
require them to her 45 layers like I
don't know why we had to watch that I
don't know why like literally she was
taking up both of his cuffs and she took
two hours like it was so here's the
thing they actually sped it up like if
he's wearing that much armor it's very
difficult to take off otherwise you'd
like go into a war and like be off with
it in five seconds so they sped up the
armor but it was still a lot of fun they
tried to make it as romantic as possible
and you know what it was really sweet
but obviously like it changed so much
because while she's not lying to
everyone about not having sex with Damon
she's lying by Omission because she is
no longer a virgin no she lied straight
up to Allison because she said I'm still
a maiden girl oh true but and she swore
on her mother Justice for the mom her
mom would have wanted it and
with this you know uh Plan B pill a t
the maester's plan B she obviously needs
it but it's also a test because if she
drinks it
she's pretty much validating to everyone
that she [ __ ] and she's never gonna
tell everyone she [ __ ] her Christian
goal
oh I don't think she'll be tested to see
if she drank it I do I don't think so I
think that um she could say she decided
not to drink it she wouldn't just leave
it there she's thrown in the fire or
whatever I don't think that's going to
be a test but I do think she'll drink it
because she better no but her whole
thing was like I don't want to just
squeeze out kids and it's like has sex
once and now unprotected no pull out
come on girl yeah I think she'll drink
it I think uh she like she I don't think
she wants kids that was literally the
whole point of the exercise what's so
sad is that like if I wasn't so head
over heels obsessed with denira as a
couple I love sir Kristen Cole I think
he's such a nice boy he is like kind of
common but like also has a little Noble
blood he's a nice good guy new episode
of the good guys is out today
um so I act like in another life I would
be thrilled he's not a powerful enough
match for her he's too common he does
nothing for her if there he does nothing
for her like if she's gonna secure a
door in a shalliance like she's gonna go
with the king of Dorne no of course but
like she's very much interested in
making a match that's
makes her happy right but but within the
confines social Royal but he's a nice
you can't just like go find Joe Schmo no
he's just a nice boy and he likes her he
is and when he finds out that he was
Plan B oh my God he's gonna be Harper
he's gonna be devastated like he's in uh
I don't know where like what happens
next like
I just know like if janeira does not
happen
I won't be okay
well I think they're happening I think
the wheels are in motion they're turning
yeah this is the plan is obviously to
get them together
yeah because the next step is for
everyone do you watch preview for next
week no I don't like to oh I do it they
don't give you like that much it's only
interesting when like I saw there was a
baby but um it's just like Otto I think
he's like
uh Eamon remember when I said there was
a toddler got it before next week
um Otto is like leaving I think he's
being banished from the castle and he's
like yelling at his daughter to make
Eamon King okay I did feel bad for him
because while he wasn't lying but he is
like a self-serving little [ __ ] and I
don't really like him and he is like
serving his own self-interest but he's
also a good hand to the king but like
you can't really be that great if you're
obsessed with your family you know it
was time for him to go but it's like you
he might have killed your dad and now
it's time yeah no it's like of all the
things like the one time he actually is
telling the truth like you didn't find
it a little weird when he shoved his
teenage daughter in your bed the second
your wife died like there's so many
other things that like actually made him
a bad hand to the king and this one he
actually handled with great discrep
discretion discretion he was pretty
respectful
um so like why now why this rumor
because rhaenyra put her foot down and
and looking right now we're getting
everything She Wants in in just the
blink of a nurse of one episode I love
to see her just really taking what's
hers you know Damon yeah I saw something
not a spoiler anything
but I think there's about to be no don't
no just up we've talked about this
just that they
the time is moving very quickly oh okay
that doesn't bother me yes but you know
uh someone told me my friend you know
the character who plays ranera like when
she grows up we get a different
character it's like that's what I was
gonna say that's what I was going to say
so I think what from what I hate that by
the way I know but like do we get a new
demon I don't think so oh by the way if
we get a new demon I'm leaving I'm done
she just looks so young right here which
is she's at this age where you actually
look different as you grow up like once
you're 40 you look the same right but I
think Rainier and Millie Alcock is the
actress I think she's like 23.
so she we must be going like 10 years
ahead if she really's gotta go I really
like the actress so I'm not thrilled 22.
that sucks
hold on
what are you looking up
I just saw like a related woman in the
search for Millie Alcock and I'm just
wondering if she's the next rainy era
yeah she could be anyone I don't want to
know that's my rhaenyra sorry like
nothing but respect for mine Rainier but
you would have thought that about like
the crown Claire forway is my queen
right right Olivia Coleman is also my
queen and Imelda Staunton is also my
queen 100. uh we can be changed we can
be changed but the show was just so good
this episode was so good and I'm just so
grateful for the incest really but what
I was going to say is I think next
episode is our last episode with Millie
oh my God I thought you were gonna say
last episode of the Season I'm like
seriously [ __ ] these people like
[ __ ] these people they don't want us to
have any Joy
yeah no Game of Thrones doesn't pull
that actually they do they're like
remember they took two years off they
took two years off and came back with
Eight Episodes yeah like towards the end
they were giving it like low effort they
were giving us
nothing
um
but also so in the beginning of the
episode when she's coming back on the
ship and then she realizes she's near
Dragonstone she stopped off and saw
Damon yeah
wait sorry what in the beginning of the
episode they're on a ship coming back
from the attorney or from the tour from
the husband tour and a dragon swoops in
so she looks up and she realizes there's
Dragonstone
which is where Damon lives
but wasn't Damon was just returning from
the war
no then I think she stopped over to see
him who knows what happened then she
goes home he comes in with his crown and
she said she said you look so
comfortable at Dragonstone it was like a
small thing I missed it completely I
don't know if I what I saw was right I
question everything now I feel like I'm
like really missing
the point oh by the way how did you feel
seeing the [ __ ] again what's she up to
oh my God when he woke up in that broth
home this [ __ ] [ __ ] was back I was
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] get out of here
I wasn't sure if she was like keeping
actually keeping him a prisoner like he
looked like he was drugged right also I
don't understand how like he can go do a
one-man battle with all of the crab
feeders Army you know literally gut him
and drag him through the beach but like
can't handle a hangover and is laying on
the floor of the throne room maybe he
has a broken heart
maybe he gets migraines like me 100 he's
prone to migraines for sure
it's the yeah it's possible no I my eyes
were old for like 360 degrees when I saw
that [ __ ] I'm like get the [ __ ] out of
here but it sounds like she's gotten out
of the flesh business and also looked
like she was in the human trafficking
business like why were those kids
handing her money and I think that kid
was the Spy the snitch yes
so she's working for Otto so he's being
betrayed
also what are we gonna do about his
first wife she's gotta go I'm not
worried about her they'll you know chop
her head off or something she's gotta go
the bronze [ __ ] like I'm not worried
about her in the slightest okay because
Rainier is nobody's like second when he
said second wife I'm like how dare you
seriously dare you one of many no no
disgusting
um let's do a little bit more TV recap I
just want to give my thoughts on Beverly
Hills and yours on Southern Charm and
it's brought to you by Bruce Bruce is an
electric toothbrush that will change the
way you think about brushing your teeth
with powerful Sonic technology and Ultra
Gentle bristles the brush redefines what
it means to have super clean teeth it's
like that feeling when you just leave
the dentist a fresh whole mouth clean
every single day so the electric
toothbrush when you get the elect the
brush kit which is what I have you get
to choose your color they have like
stunning colors it's giving Fashion Week
you get three different brush heads the
toothbrush itself a magnetic charging
station and a Sleek travel case so the
great thing about the Bruce is that once
you fully charge it it literally can
last last so long that you can travel
without the charger if you're traveling
for like a weekend or even a week but
it's also like very no must no fuss it's
not like this big bulky thing you can
maintain like your clean clutter-free
energy with the brush I have it in pink
and like magenta and like Millennial
pink Ben has it in like a hunter green
it's everything my teeth have never been
more stunning take a look at my pearly
whites and you can get 20 off when you
pick your brush brush kit and plan at
brush.com toast that's 20 off when you
go to
b-r-u-u-s-h.com slash toast brush.com
slash toast
so the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
I kind of hit like a low point but this
most recent week was really powerful
because they went to Aspen and
apparently like Aspen is where
everything goes down and while I think
the thing we're waiting for
to happen doesn't go down it was still a
really interesting episode
um one you know they're going back and
forth about the same [ __ ] but after one
night
um Erica gets like black out
and they're just talking about the
victims and the conversation starts with
a garcelle crystal and maybe Diana
asking Erica questions and she's like
not her typical kind of political
answers she's just going in she's like
these victims are not my problem I don't
care about them uh you guys only care
about them because of what the public
thinks and all the other women are on
the couch but they slowly start like
hearing what she's saying and you know
Sutton who has been Erica's biggest you
know investigator slash critique
she is just sitting and listening and
absorbing because honestly I don't think
anyone can believe the [ __ ] that's
coming out of Erica's mouth
and her friends are like trying to
protect her which just like kind of
annoys me because like
they don't protect everyone you know if
anyone else outside of like that Core
Group dorit Rinna Kyle Erica if anyone
else was like wasted and saying crazy
things about like a scandal they were
going through like no one would protect
them and try and get them out of there
Kyle was basically like stop saying I
need all of this I won't be able to
defend you like let's get her out of
here and it's like no let her let her
just like you would let everyone else
like nobody runs and jumps in helps
Sutton
yeah and everyone is just so [ __ ]
mean to Sutton and she's so bad at
defending herself and like Marcel is
helpful but like
the way like Diana and Erica are two of
the most evil women I've ever like
basically
everyone is getting mad at Sutton for
for something and Sutton was like well
where was all this energy when literally
uh Erica called me a [ __ ]
like you guys weren't all baffled like
you know holds clutching your pearls
and Diana was like and it was quiet and
Jana was like well that's because you
are a [ __ ]
it was so mean and then her and Erica
are hysterically laughing Sutton sitting
there crying like it was and then Diana
starts to cry like it was so evil and
manipulative and I hate these this group
of women like literally I can't watch it
because I'm like actually a good person
you know and I have a moral compass and
I have feelings and I I can't watch like
this gang up of women like it's horrible
but the real turning point and I think
like I think a lot of like the big
moment that happens in Aspen has to do
with Kathy and like I don't know what
goes down but I see why she might be in
a bad mood when she wakes up
because her [ __ ] sister is just like
uses her as a punching bag I couldn't
believe it like you and I if we're in a
big group like Not only would we never
like
punch down on one another but like we're
a team you know it's almost unfair if
we're in a group because we always have
each other's backs you know right right
or wrong right or wrong like I'm gonna
defend you you're gonna defend me and
like we're never gonna like make fun of
each other like it was
first of all Kyle is just like obsessed
with putting Kathy down I think because
like the way the Housewives
fandom became obsessed with Kathy was
like historic and I don't think Kyle
particularly loved it
um so they all fly in Kathy flies in
separately from New York she walks in
the hotel like how a normal person looks
after a flight like [ __ ] disheveled
and she's wearing Hotel slippers and
Kyle can't get over that she's wearing
Hotel slippers the whole episode did you
see Kathy slippers did you see
leave her alone she's an old an old
woman traveling like leave her alone
seriously yeah that night they all go
out to dinner
Kathy who's like you know actually rich
and doesn't need to like prove it by
wearing a Birkin her purse for the night
is like one of those like reusable free
people shopping bags that you get from
the store like it's it's like one of
those totes that you get when you spend
like a hundred dollars it's not a purse
it's like a tote yeah the Brooklyn in
one I love it yeah I have an aloe yoga
one like the [ __ ] that you would throw
in like to go to the gym yeah
Kyle takes the purse is showing every
look at this coffee godly's back like
just trying to embarrass her or do you
think it's like Kyle trying to play to
the fans but getting it wrong like no
like how last season everything Kathy
did like I don't think anybody thought
every single thing like time she did
something silly or funny it was gonna be
a moment and now it's like Kyle realized
that and I was trying to like capitalize
on every one of Kathy's moments maybe
but it did not seem
um
Kyle didn't bring it up then the fans
would be like oh my God Kathy Queen like
wearing a reusable tote like we'd love
to see it and so like Kyle's like
injecting herself into that moment okay
I didn't get that energy at all but like
perhaps I didn't watch it I'm just I'm
just listening to you and then the final
thing was like so after this dinner they
all go back to uh the rental house and
that's where Erica has this like
meltdown
um but before that like the women are
like doing weed gummies they're like
drunk and for sure it wasn't the right
moment for Kathy to like want to talk
about this but it's clear she's not a
professional housewife she don't know
she doesn't know when the right time to
promote a product is but she basically
is talking about this tequila that she
has she's like you know Paris is an
investor I'm an investor Nikki and her
husband James are investors it's so good
like I would love for you guys to try it
like she wasn't being like calculated
she was did she have it with her yeah
Casa del Sol and they're sitting around
drinking so it's like yeah I mean some
women have stopped drinking a lot of
them are doing pot but like Kathy is not
she doesn't she sees people drinking
she's like great perfect time to talk
about my tequila and like these women
who cannot promote enough [ __ ] things
are so dismissive no who wants to kill
her right now oh my God Kathy your
timing is horrible like being so mean to
this old lady like it was so sad
especially Kyle what did she say he got
it like nobody wants to do that right
now like it was so mean especially when
they think of like all the [ __ ] events
all these women have to go to for their
other and the [ __ ] we have to sit
through it was so and how much tequila
they drink it was so [ __ ] mean and
Paris actually responded to a Tweet
someone was like I cannot believe how
all the women just like literally
dismissed the hell out of Kathy and I
think the tweets had Kyle Kyle yeah
Paris retweeted him it was like they
were so unkind so there's definitely Bad
Blood between Kathy and Kyle
currently currently messed up and then
something about 818 that's next week
they order 818 my DVR cut off before the
preview so I don't know what the 818
like thing is but it seems like they're
in a situation where Casa del Sol is
offered and they order 818.
that's [ __ ] up
yeah
um are you tell me about southern charm
because I have about six minutes left
this is the longest episode of my life I
have six minutes left on my memory card
because we're about to literally run out
of storage because okay I'll just tell
you Southern Charm and I think I caught
you guys up till Thanksgiving like
things are Brewing between Paige and
Naomi it's so crazy how like Paige
really doesn't want to come to
Charleston and like be on the show I
think and I think Craig even said this
when we interviewed him how it's like
they don't enjoy doing each other's
shows he doesn't like doing something
else because it's like a 24 7 camera and
she doesn't like doing like the group
trips and his shows and I think she just
doesn't like how like they operate in
the South where everyone's like sweet to
your face and like rude behind your back
where she's very much a new worker and
it's like we're just rude 24 7. but also
like she um her job is being on a
reality show and now like her private
time with her boyfriend like she also
has to do her job you know yeah but I
would just think like if you're a
reality star and it's more shows and
that's your business like I would have
just thought they'd be like yeah I'll
come to all the brass they went to this
Frank Lloyd Wright House a few weeks ago
and it was actually pretty cool it was a
crazy episode
um and she did not go I missed her
dearly but she did come to Austin's
friendsgiving like being and looking
like the queen that she is she had it
out with Naomi but they had made a
wrapper of shma and everything's good
then this week Patricia hosted the boys
for a boys night dinner white tie at her
house like French style cooking like so
[ __ ] Pat and Leva had the girls at
one of her restaurants for a girl's
night and by the way I do believe leva's
getting her own show Vanderpump rule
style about her restaurants that'll be
good and love is just becoming like a
voice of reason within the group she's
not really injecting herself into the
drama like she did last season and I
just I really appreciate her energy and
her advice like she's really a great um
she's a great gal and girl's night is
going really really well considering
like Catherine and Naomi yeah [ __ ]
hate each other but Naomi is now in the
show hooking up with Whitney and like
I thought I thought it was gonna be like
they kissed once uh like drunk after uh
dog wedding or something but no they're
like seeing each other sort of wow and I
I don't really hate it I mean I think
Patricia would like love to have Naomi
as her daughter-in-law and Whitney's
like really thinks she's like the
classiest woman in the world and like
just worships the ground that she walks
on are they still together now I don't
think so but if they were I really would
be here for it and like I kind of bonded
Catherine Naomi because Catherine was
like Whitney's actually a great guy a
great catch and like really genuine and
I think like that meant a lot for Naomi
to here because I think everyone was
kind of like giving her [ __ ] giving her
[ __ ] like because Whitney's it's weird
yeah kind of weird
um but when they went to this uh retreat
at Frank Lloyd Wright House it's like
this you know historical landmark house
of course it's like Whitney's friend
owns it and Whitney did all the rooms
and everyone's like bunking together
except like he gave Naomi like the
choice of four different rooms and was
like taking her in a private tour like
would you want that one or this one it's
a really cute she's getting like special
treatment
um so when the boys were at Pat's house
they were so drunk it was so funny and
they were genuinely having a good ass
time and we only see the drama with this
group and it's like sometimes the
drama's so loud it's like why and how
are you still friends but then they are
you see moments like this and like they
have so much fun together and it's a
genuine joy to watch even Whitney is
like just being so funny and Patricia
fostered that for us so I'm happy for
her
and I'm appreciating her more now I
don't know what changed but I'm just and
all her furniture is like breaking it's
LOL like the boys are like drunk in her
chairs and they're you know like 16 100
year old chairs yeah Craig broke a chair
then Whitney broke his chair that's
actually really funny and that's why
like at the end of the day like that
show is good and successful because it's
not a group of people who only get
together to film like they are real
friends with real history that was like
shots of sunset too rest in peace rest
in peace so that was great and then I
just wanted to update you guys on the
books that I read this weekend because I
finished the historical fiction book I
was reading by Beach I have 90 seconds
left on my oh my God okay I read the
secret life of violet Grant um amazing
historical fiction book really long I
would give it four and a half stars but
like it pays off if you want to like
really be immersed in a story I loved it
then I read Jenny Mullins book city of
girls yeah which I'm okay we are not
going to do your end of recap show Once
once you're done we're done okay okay
city of girls by jelly Mullen it's like
all about influencer mamas mom
influencers and it was actually really
good I read it in less than 24 hours and
I enjoyed it immensely she talked so
much about influencers but I really feel
like she gets it right most of the time
and it was really well written and
really easy to read so I would recommend
and then I just started the new Taylor
Jenkins read book Carrie soda is back
about the tennis players so um like five
pages in that's that okay uh that was
our literally two year long show
tomorrow will be on bird in your cells
we love you all sorry